[Music]
let's roll out to Tampa Florida and talk
to Amy hey Amy what's up hey Dr John
thanks so much for taking my call of
course what's going on hey so I'm going
to go ahead if it's okay and read the
letter that I submitted um how do I know
when to let my 13-year-old daughter
control her own health and nutrition
she's been struggling with weight for so
many years we have tried everything um
you tell parents how we put bricks in
our back in our kids backpacks all the
time so how do I help her do I stop and
if she gains 600 lbs do I make it as her
choice I'm tired of talking about food
and exercise all the time all the time
she can't put a piece of food in her
mouth without feeling judged so I'm not
looking for nutrition or exercise help
from you how do I let my daughter know
she is seen and she is loved and she is
not judged
where does she get that message that
she's being
judged um well I've noticed over the
past year or so that um she goes and
eats in her room she'd prefer to eat in
her room because then she she actually
said if I go and I have my meal in my
room then I can eat in peace and I don't
feel like someone's looking at me
whether it's me or whether it's Dad or
her brothers um because of her weight
gain over the years I'm trying to help
her with portion control control and you
know better choices and making sure we
have healthy food um but I just feel
like just her personality her demeanor
she just I don't know she just she gets
M she asks me if I get mad at her like
if she's still hungry and she wants
seconds she's like well are you mad
because I want seconds are you mad
because I put too much salt are you mad
because I chose you know I don't know I
just um how long have you been after her
for this years at least four years she's
probably gained 100 pounds in the last
four years what changed in her life four
years
ago um school got rough and Co made it
you know worse um so she was home a lot
had a lot more access to food and it can
be healthy food it's not just you know
junk food that she loves to eat it can
be healthy food that she just likes to
eat what happened what happened at
home um I don't know I've thought about
that cuz I had a feeling ask I can't
really pinpoint any particular thing um
that may have caused
it are you and your husband overweight
are you all super fit we are fit we are
fit and um she knows that I had
struggled with weight when I was her age
and kind of got that together 30 years
ago and yes we are very and that's the
thing we try to set a model for her that
we have healthy foods her brothers are
fit we all exercise
daily um and then you know I've
encouraged her it has to be something
she likes to do I like to run she's not
a runner her dad's not a runner so I'm
like let's do something fun we put her
in classes gymnastics we play tennis we
dance she's big into theater um I
just I don't know and I guess I guess
what I really need your help with this
is do I just let her do her own thing
because I I find myself every time is
eating looking at what she's eating and
how much she's eating because she does
ask me Mom you got to help me you want
to please help me I don't want to be
this way but then when I do help her
then she gets upset with me because she
doesn't like what I have to say or if I
restrict her and tell her that's because
that's not the question she's asking
you okay the question she's asking you
is Mommy why don't you love
me
H and kids don't know how to ask that
question and so they say are you proud
of me do you like my Straight A's did
you see that goal I
scored did you see how I lost five
pounds they're not asking you to look at
the scale or look at the soccer ball
they're saying am I finally enough am I
enough
now yeah and whether it's genetic
whether it's learned behavior whether
it's all of that stuff
combined it sounds like your daughter's
been asking for a long long time do y
all love me and when she gets an answer
that's conditional M she goes to the
behavior again whether learned whether
genetic whether
whatever
um that makes her body her shoulders
drop finally and then it starts the
shame spiral again and then she starts
saying does anybody see me does anybody
love me it's kind of like I don't know
if your husband does this but when you
say man I had a really rough day and
your husband says well let's just call
him let's call him right now let's tell
your boss that he's not hearing you cuz
what you're saying when you say I had a
really rough day is not I had a really
rough day and since you're so smart and
wonderful husband will you solve my
problems for me that's not what you're
saying you're saying do you do you still
love
me and I think for a long long long time
your daughter's known she's not good
enough she's not doing let me say it
this way she's not doing it
right well whatever it is she's not
doing life
right and she watches her brothers get
praised she watches you and your husband
praise each other
and that little part of her body in her
brain says we're not welcome
here and so no I think it would be a I
think you all have gotten into a dance
over the last four years and probably
started before this and here's the
dance
she comes in and get something to eat
she catches you you wise she catches you
glance out of the corner of your eye and
she knows I'm being judged I'm out of
here or I'm going to eat this and the
only thing that makes her feel better is
eating again because she doesn't have
access to alcohol or cigarettes or sex
or any other stuff that make that that
grown-ups use or
busyness
and then when she goes into her room she
hears you and is this enough mom well I
wouldn't the it's just a dance but
youall need desperate ly is professional
intervention not on the Food Part will
come you'll have to address that but
what you really need
is she's got you'll have to go through a
season where she knows you and your
husband love her no matter what and that
can't just be saying we love you yep you
see what I'm
saying and I hate having this
conversation with moms especially
because moms take this hard as though
you failed something right yes
and you try to make it right by
[Music]
overcontrolled wheel it's not good
parenting right so you find yourself
stuck and so what I would tell you to do
is you got to learn a new way to
interact with your
baby yep now as I'm saying this does
that ring true or tell me how I sound
like out to lunch no it does it does
ring true and um I've tried a couple of
different counselors okay um I'm I'm not
a fan of therapy Dr John until I started
listening to his show why weren't why
weren't you a fan I'm not I just I
always raised you don't we fix it in the
house you know I was raised in a
Christian home and you know we pray
about things and we fix it um within our
home and and that's it gosh dude that's
so damaging I hope you know that now
yeah I mean I've learned a lot of things
and um it's just such a different
relationship though the way I was raised
and I you know as as a parent you try to
do the right things that were right in
your home and um you know I've never had
any issues with my boys as far as you
know that kind of thing and parenting
but okay so I want to tell you something
I'm going to use the word trauma and
don't don't over respond to that because
I'm not saying there's any trauma in
your house
okay but I've mentioned I think I
mentioned this on the last episode I
just shot um one of the I did a
practicum with gave me some langu he one
time I we were look talking about some
some kids we were working with and I
said well that one's going to be okay
and he looked at me and said hey you
know that straight A's can be a trauma
response
to and some kids their biology is
heavy some kids they're um they say do
you love me and they set something on
fire and other kids go make perfect
scores on things and they say do you
love me and we Pat one on the head and
we give send one to college for free and
we put the other one in
jail the
response is the same I'm sorry the
response is different but the underlying
pathology is the
same you see what I'm
saying yeah and we have I mean I and
even though you know I'm I'm definitely
opened I've learned a lot from listening
to your show and you know I I have a
friend that I've talked to that you know
I've basically said you know I just gosh
I wish I could just fix her I wish I
could just fix the way that she wants to
be and I had a brave friend say to me
one time she's not broken yes she's not
a project she's not a project to be
fixed and so who told you that about
you uh told me I was broken yep um I
grew up I grew up with a father who was
very critical of my
weight so yeah that was and my brother
jumped on board a couple of times and
you know thought it was okay CU if Dad
said it and Dad's in charge you know
then it was you know it was like fair
game in the house so but I you know I'm
I'm good I come to terms with all of
that and I got it together you know
probably in my 20s when I just um it
worked for me and I figured it out hold
on that's the language you got to be
careful
of I quote unquote got it together
because then you pass that on your
daughter get it together yep right yeah
and often when go to AA and they quit
drinking they all start
smoking they trade one for the
other and if you traded food for I'm in
the gym seven days a week and I count
every single morsel of every you just
traded one for the other you might live
longer but you're
not I can call you healthier
metabolically but you haven't addressed
the core problem that your dad you were
never enough
or your love to your old man was
conditional on how you looked how your
plate
looked you see what I'm saying
yeah Y and listen Amy this is a guy with
two phds because I had a really really
Savant smart sister and a brother who
missed two questions on the ACT and I've
been desperately chasing the question
will y'all tell me I'm smart too cuz I
was just a dumb
jock I've been chasing and chasing and
chasing until finally I just quit and
had to deal with
it and come to find out there was a
bunch of stupid stories I was telling
myself yeah but here's what we're doing
we have go ahead go ahead sry I was just
gonna say we have I have um I got our
counselor came highly recommended um
unfortunately about two months in she
doesn't need one okay y'all need one she
will and that's what I'm figuring out
that it's not her yall it's the dynamic
in her home that she does not have the
tools to
address so instead of saying why are you
eating that or are you really hungry or
can you substitute that for something
healthier M ask yourself what is her
body trying to protect her from in her
very own
home okay and it might be the way
everyone's looking at her or it might be
that she only gets talked to when she
after after the workouts over
or it might be
dad or she hears dad and brother making
fun of the overweight girl on
TV see what I'm saying yeah her body is
trying to defend her in her own home and
if y'all had alcohol where she could
access it she she's on a she'll get it
soon and if she finds some boy to tell
her that she's beautiful she'll man
she'll be all over that
too she just doesn't have access
yet this is about defense this is not
about your daughter's broken and so
maybe for a season look at her and say
her body's working
perfectly what in the world is it trying
to defend her
from and I'm also not one of these guys
who says like has F jumped on this
bandwagon it dude our health in this
country is a train
wreck yeah it's not good
and I'm not I would be lying to somebody
and dishonoring them if I said not being
obese is great it's not every part of
your day is
harder every part okay so that's not
what I'm saying here but what I'm saying
here is to get to that part in a healthy
way you'll have to address the system
inside that home and I think your
daughter may be a an alarm system for
the
home does that does that ring true or
no um yeah I think in some parts it does
but in I and I think you know that's
that's what I'm looking for that's kind
of the answer I was looking for for you
is I I'm realizing there is nothing
wrong with her it's the way you know I
see it or I address it or my husband
sees it or my husband addresses it
there's there's absolutely nothing wrong
with her so but I just
feel I feel horrible that as her mom she
doesn't feel
like safe in our home like I get that I
get that I totally get
that I can't think of a more devastating
thing to feel and I felt it because I
was told that
and the people who told me that were
right I was a nuclear ball of energy in
my daughter's body a little bitty baby
girl who was 5 years old B boing around
my house said that dude is not
safe I didn't hit her I didn't yell I
don't raise my voice in my house I was a
great
dad but dude I was a nuclear
reactor and so I think I think the
here's the conversation I think I think
the conversation begins with um hey
honey I I don't even know where to start
other
than we've created a home that's just
not safe for
you and we've wrapped it up in doing all
the things perfectly but in trying to
achieve all the perfect things we've
made a very unstable house and I'm
sorry and I don't know what to do but
here's my promise I promise I'm going to
work on
it and I think your whole family needs
to go to a family counselor all of you
together and there has to be a family
counselor that's willing to take you and
your husband on because my guess is
y'all are a force of Nature and they
need to be able to take y'all on
an needs to be able to honestly address
your
daughter because she does have some very
unhealthy
habits it's both
and but I wouldn't send her to a
counselor and be like she just needs to
get fixed and I wouldn't go to counselor
if I was you and just be like I need the
right thing to say to my daughter so
she'll eat better no dude her body's
trying to protect her from a house that
lets her know has let her know for a
season ah you're not really enough for
us you got to fix some stuff then you'll
be on the inside like your
brothers and God Almighty I know how
hard that is to hear I've I cringe as a
parent saying that to another parent
because I know how hard that is to
hear but the the evidence is the pattern
for four years you've tried a thing and
it hasn't worked and your daughter's put
on 100 pounds in four
years let's throw up our hands and say
okay what I'm doing is not
working let's try something
else but I know how devastating and and
um um fatal disordered eating can be and
so I would go see somebody ASAP
professional in your
area for you for your husband for your
sons and for that sweet girl of yours
and along the way I want you to address
the fact that you were only loved when
you looked right to your dad and let's
let this thing stop right now this is
what leg and family tree change looks
like thanks for the call
Amy